welcome back to cbs this morning and
we're going to begin with this
a florida judge is blocking state
officials from forcing public schools in
that state to restart
in-person classes during the pandemic
the judge
issued a temporary injunction ruling the
state quote
essentially ignore the requirement of
school safety close quote
florida governor ron desantis and the
state said they plan to appeal the
decision and our manuel pojorquez is
outside
a high school in miami beach following
all these developments manny good
morning to you
good morning the head of the largest
teachers union in the state calls it a
victory for teachers
students and employees but the ruling
comes as some students
are already returning to classrooms and
districts around the state
it is our government's responsibility to
provide for
a safe and secure public school for
every child
in the state of florida that's frederick
ingram president of the largest teachers
association in the southeast
his union represents nearly 150 000
teachers and school employees in florida
they should be
brought back in a manner that was
comprehensive that was strategic and
that was guided by science and guided by
healthcare professionals
the florida department of education had
ordered most schools to reopen for
in-person learning or risk losing state
funding
despite positive cases in the state now
surpassing 600 thousand
but the judge's order should slow the
reopening down for now
the governor has appealed the decision
in new york city mayor bill de blasio is
taking action to make
in-person classes safer he says
principals can apply by this friday to
create
outdoor classes in their school yards
we're going to focus on the 27
neighborhoods
hardest hit by covet 19. we're going to
prioritize making sure that they get
options for outdoor space but across the
country
more signs of the difficulties of
reopening schools and college campuses
over the weekend students at auburn
university packed tightly into a bar
many without masks at the university of
southern california
43 positive cases have been linked to
off-campus housing
now more than 100 students are
quarantined the truth is is that fall in
tuscaloosa
is in serious jeopardy in tuscaloosa
alabama mayor walt maddox announced
yesterday that all bars in town would
close for 14 days
to get a handle on a spike in covid
cases on the university of alabama
campus and in the city
the university is reporting 531 cases
will these measures combined with ua's
efforts ensure success
the truth is we don't know however the
failure to do nothing
will cost more lives and livelihoods
also concerning health officials a new
report out of hong kong released monday
suggests
some people could get the coronavirus
twice
dr anita rodan with florida
international university
says more needs to be known about the
different strains of the virus
after the patient in the report was
reinfected four and a half months after
first catching it
does this give us a sense of how long we
may
have immunity with antibodies just one
case
is not enough however the impetus now
would be to then see whether it is the
true vi the same virus
or it could just be that the virus goes
into a dormant state and then resurfaces
again
back to schools as many students begin
the process
of remote learning there have already
been some issues
yesterday a global zoom outage in the
morning interrupted classes
for thousands of students gail yeah
people were very upset about that too
thank you very much manuel we need the
zoom